you love taking shirt off more than
anything
you know when something becomes meme it
becomes super popular it uh
it becomes easy to not love the thing
anymore to get tired of it you still
love it well more than anything
I like being shirtless
more than having a shirt I'm very
uncomfortable in a shirt yeah like right
now and I've tactile issues like I have
legit tactile issues
I'm most comfortable in stretchy jeans
with a loose fitting belt and then these
shirts exactly but I don't I like more
like a v-neck I can feel this on my neck
right now and I can feel it on my arms
and so I'm
I'll sit a certain way because it it
just rubs me wrong
be a more comfortable shirtless I can
never wear what you're wearing
uh yeah well this is my shirtless each
of us have to find our place in this
world in terms of fashion I would love
to be able to wear what you wear yeah
because it looks good it feels like an
escape from convention
it's you or me both of us yeah because
this nobody wears this
unless you work security for somebody
yeah but it looks good on you does it I
don't know you know I think people think
I don't like they would say like what
what if you lose weight you can't take
your shirt off anymore go no I can
[__] take my shirt off yeah you
[__] out of your mind I'm gonna take
my shirt off all the time